[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES DANIELS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Firebase applications--
we've written an SDK for you
in iOS Android, mobile web,
lots of other frameworks.
And that SDK communicates
to the Firebase service.
There is no
intermediary gatekeeper.
There's no servers.
Google handles all
of that for you
with a suite of tools that are
called directly from the SDK
itself, very powerful
managed services that
allow you to focus
on building an app
rather than working on
all of the boilerplate.
So we have authentication, we
have our Realtime Database,
we have Cloud messages, and
lots more products there.
And really, it's to empower
you to deliver products faster
without worrying about all the
DevOps and stuff like that.
There's also the
Realtime Database.
How this is differentiated
from a traditional database
is the Realtime Database
synchronizes changes
to all the listening
clients, all the clients that
are interested in a specific
spot on the database
in milliseconds.
And this allows you to
build very rich applications
for free with
Firebase, none of this
having to spin up servers
and juggle sockets
and lots of complicated things.
So it's a nice little addition
to the Firebase product.
And if you were to
build your own servers,
you'd have to build
all of that as well.
But there are problems
in this thick client
model promoted by Firebase.
It's not without its
disadvantages, right?
So while Firebase gives
you a very powerful tool
to validate the data
coming into your database,
to validate the users'
writing, reading files--
this is our rules engine--
there are things
that you can't quite
do in Firebase without
Cloud Functions.
So say you wanted to perform
an expensive operation.
You want to resize a image
or transcode a video.
This is something
that would burn up
your user's battery, very likely
to uninstall your application
if you do that.
And just, you know,
it's going to make
your application slower.
And again, it's just
a lot of complexity.
It's just shifting that
complexity to the clients.
So now you need to know how
to resize an image on iOS,
Android, and then
you're going to have
to do it on the web for
all kinds of trickery.
So say you didn't want
to trust the client.
The Realtime Database has
a very powerful rules set,
but you can't encapsulate
everything in there.
Say you wanted to
moderate images.
Say you wanted to filter
out adult language.
What if you have secrets?
What if you have private
keys, API tokens, things
that you don't
want on the client?
Clients cannot be
trusted, right?
That's just an application
on their phone.
It could be cracked open.
They can look at the secrets.
They can grab those.
So they don't want to put things
like your push notification
gateway secrets in there to
allow peer-to-peer messaging.
That would be leaking those,
and someone could actually
crack the application,
grab that secret,
and message your users en masse.
That's no good.
Say you have a proprietary
algorithm, interact
with a third party, or,
for whatever reason,
you need to expose a
classic HTTP end point.
These are all things that
are hard to do on Firebase.
So in the good old days,
you'll say, this was easier.
My server, it's mine.
I control it.
I can make whatever APIs I want.
I can do whatever I
want to do on there.
So why don't we combine them?
So say we attach generic compute
to Firebase just using it
as a regular old client.
So it's listening to
changes to the database.
It's then writing
into the database.
In fact, until
recently, this was
pushed as a best practice
by the Firebase team
with tools like
Firebase Q, where
you would write into a
part of the database things
that you wanted these listening
clients to do, these workers.
But now you have
this problem again.
Now you have these workers,
these generic compute.
You have to scale them.
You have to pay for
the excess capacity.
And then you're going to have
all kinds of troubles coming
around where, oh, what if two
workers are doing the same job?
Then you're going to have a lot
of bikeshedding about the way
that the Firebase
Realtime Database is,
and why aren't we using MySQL?
And wasn't Firebase supposed
to make all of this easy
after all?
It promised to make us
deliver applications faster.
And now we're here
bikeshedding, talking
about how to scale
these workers,
and now we need to
spin up a DevOps team.
It's no good.
So that's why, recently,
the Firebase team
launched Cloud Functions
for Firebase into beta.
So how Cloud Functions
for Firebase works
is, instead of spinning
up general compute
and attaching it to Firebase,
we have event-driven code
execution.
It will scale up with
your usage and then
down to zero when not in use.
And you're only paying for
those milliseconds that you use.
This allows us to provide
a minimal glue that
allows you to stitch all of
Firebase's products together.
So I mentioned event-driven.
So what this is is you
actually write snippets of code
that listen to an event.
This is Node.js code.
Those functions
are each isolated.
They're all running separately,
so if one of them crashes,
it doesn't take down the other.
And when those events
come in through Pub/Sub,
it will execute
that code, and it'll
either write back
to the database
or trigger some other action.
So you can do things
like listen to a database
write, then the code
can sanitize the input
and write to another
spot on the database.
So let's see this in action.
So here's a very
minimal example.
This is probably the
basis example every time
you see something.
You have a helloWord
function here.
So this is an HTTP function.
This allows us to
spin up an API.
So this HTTP
function is actually
in the Express.js style.
And then it sends,
"Hello world!"
So this is an HTTP request.
It is synchronous.
We don't want to be doing
a sync work on this.
We want to send a response
as quick as we can.
So let's jump to a more
complicated example.
So here's one where
we're actually
listening to the database.
So up here, we're actually
initialising Firebase functions
and the admin SDK for Firebase.
We're pulling in
the configuration
and initializing Firebase admin.
We're then listening on
the database, this ref.
And those are wildcards.
Those'll be parsed
into our parameters.
And then onCreate means it's
a database insert rather than
an update or destroy.
It sends an event object.
We pull the current value.
We pull the username from
that, the text, title body,
and we send it to the
room ID on an FCM topic.
So what does this do?
When a message is
posted to a chat room,
it will notify,
through FCM, push
notifications, all subscribers,
regardless of platform.
This could be iOS.
This could be Android.
This could be the web.
And magically, they're going to
get this and very little code.
We run this.
This is an independent function.
We just deploy this.
And Google is going to
handle all of the scaling
up and scaling down as needed.
So what type of
things do we have?
You already saw
the HTTPS function.
That allows you to send
an Express.js response.
This Express.js
object, it doesn't
have to be as simple as
just that response send.
You can actually create
an Express.js application.
It could be your full JSON API.
So where I had that
"Hello world!",
that will match
any path on there.
So you could just have
exports API and then give it
an Express application that
has your entire JSON API.
There is also Cloud
Pub/Sub triggers.
So Cloud Pub/Sub
allows you to do
durable publish and subscribe.
This would allow you to take--
say, if you do have a
server, you could actually
be writing to a
Pub/Sub queue, and then
have Node.js executed whenever
anything triggers on that.
Cloud Storage for Firebase--
so when files are uploaded,
you can perform
operations on them.
Firebase Hosting--
so this integration
allows you, when you're
using Firebase static website
hosting, to write proxy calls.
So you can put in URL pattern
matches that will redirect you
to a specified Cloud Function.
So I mentioned the API case.
There we go.
That allows you to
take our static hosting
and make it dynamic.
There's also the Firebase
Realtime Database, as you saw,
and there's Firebase
authentication.
So when users are created,
you can trigger code.
So a good use case for
this is, say, you're
storing user settings in
your Realtime Database,
and you want to set
some defaults there,
or you want to interact
with a third party
and, say, set up a
customer record in Stripe,
or subscribe them to your
mailing list on SendGrid.
You could actually
do this with that.
And you can actually pull in
those third-party libraries.
I mentioned these are Node.js.
So you can actually pull
in these dependencies
if they have a Node.js
module available on NPM.
And then there's Google
Analytics for Firebase.
So those great Google
Analytics conversion events,
you can actually listen
for them and trigger code.
So say a user does
an in-app purchase.
You could send them an
FCM saying thank you.
Or you could write somewhere
in the database marking them
as a VIP customer.
And there's many
more coming soon.
If you're interested in the
additional triggers that are
coming with Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
I recommend that you
join our alpha program,
so firebase.google.com/alpha.
So I'm asking you to take Cloud
Functions to your customers.
It wouldn't really be fair if
I wasn't willing to embarrass
myself on stage.
So time for a live demo.
So what I've created
here is actually
an integration with Twilio.
So praying to the live demo
gods that this will work.
So let's start, actually,
by saying hello.
Hm.
It wants me to send it pictures.
Let's grab one
from my web camera.
Now, let's see what it says.
It's analyzing.
That's promising.
"Awesome hair," that's
what it picked up.
Let's send it another one.
Analyzing.
Dah-da-da, dah-da-da, da-da!
"Music."
Hm.
Cloud Vision didn't quite know
what to think of Doc Brown.
So how did I accomplish this?
Let's show you the code.
So here, I actually have my
Twilio messaging callback.
So what I've done here is
create an HTTPS trigger, Twilio
messaging callback.
I glanced on this, but that is
actually the root of the URL.
So it'll be my Cloud
Function's domain slash
Twilio messaging callback
will actually be the URL.
And that, of course, will
pattern match on anything
after that part.
So this would be, where if
you are setting up an API,
you could just do flash API,
pass in an Express application.
But in this case, I'm just
going to define it all here.
So I have an HTTPS on
request, Express.js.
So this is-- actually,
a lot of this code
here is just dealing
with the format
that Twilio is
sending me the MMS in.
So I'm looking at the
number of pictures.
If it's zero, I say,
"Send me pictures!
Nom nom."
Else, I'm going to create
a payload because, well,
maybe the MMSes were batched.
Maybe it sent more than
one at the same time.
So I'm going to insert these
into the Realtime Database.
So here I go.
I loop over them, add
to this update payload,
and then I insert
into the database.
So I do an update, then
I'm sending Twilio ML.
So this is actually an XML API.
And here you can actually
see, I have a little helper.
down here.
Send TwiML, response type XML,
send, and then the XML there.
So that is actually
inserting into the database.
So I'll actually show you
where those are coming in.
So there we have
the inbound MMS.
You can see them
coming to the database.
And I have a couple
extra parameters
here that were not for, from
and to, and URL, which I set.
So those are coming in from
these pair of functions.
So these functions here are
independent of each other.
They're running in parallel.
They don't know
about each other.
They're isolated.
So here they're both listening
to the inbound MMS push ID,
and they're listening
for that insert.
So what this is doing is
grabbing the image URL,
and it's using the
Cloud Vision API.
So that's just an NPM
module that I initialized.
And it's doing label
detection on those.
I send it the image URI in
the format that the API wants,
and that's a promise.
So I listen for the
result of that, parse it,
and then I write
it to the database.
So this event data admin ref--
so these database
writes, by default,
are coming in as the user who
inserted it into the database.
So the Firebase
Realtime Database rules
will respect that.
If I use admin ref,
then it's saying
I want to bypass these rules.
This works in the context
of Cloud Functions
where we're admin initialized.
So here, I can actually
bypass the rules.
So my database
rules, if I wanted,
I could actually make it so that
label annotations was actually
not writeable, but the admin
ref would short-circuit that.
And then again, so that's
grabbing the label annotations.
This is also a
SafeSearch annotation.
So what I'm doing there
is parsing whether or not
it's safe for work.
So if I go back to
my Realtime Database,
we have our label annotations--
so music, that's
where that came from.
Performing arts,
performance-- well,
I guess that is performing
arts and a performance, right?
Now let's look at our
SafeSearch annotation.
So it's not very
likely to be adult
content and unlikely
to be violent.
So how did we actually then send
a response back to the user?
So let's take a
look at our code.
So here we go.
We're actually responding
to the MMS with labels.
So [? an isolated ?]
function-- so we're
listening to the database, this
inbound MMS push ID on update.
So here we're not just
listening for the insert.
We're listening for whenever
this node in the database
is actually updated.
So we're pulling in
the current value.
We're also pulling in
the previous value,
label annotations.
And what I'm looking for is that
the label annotations are not
null and that it
didn't previously
have label annotations.
So what I'm doing there is
listening for the inserts
of the label annotations.
From and to, I put
together the body,
and then the Twilio client
messages create to/from body.
And here I'm actually returning,
because the database ones allow
for asynchronous responses.
So it expects either a
promise returned, hence
the return the Twilio
client messages create,
which is a promise,
or an object.
That's the return null.
If it doesn't return
either one of these,
it's going to be treated
as an error condition.
So that is sent by
the Twilio client API,
which is just an NPM library.
And I actually initialize
it with functions.config.
So there's actually
Runtime Config
that you can set so that your
secrets are not in your code.
So we have this
SafeSearch annotation.
Where does that come into play?
That's this last function here.
So here I'm also listening.
And what I'm looking for
is, again, the insertion
of the SafeSearch annotation.
It's not an update.
I'm looking at the
previous value.
So label annotations is
null, SafeSearch null,
then we're going to return null.
Else, look for it being
unlikely or very unlikely.
If it's either one of
those, it short-circuits
and goes back here.
So then it actually writes
to a public images ref.
And there, I've made a static
website where you can actually
see these.
So it's very fast
to respond here.
That's actually because
it's through Firebase
static hosting, so it's
behind our global CDN.
And to prove that it's
static, I can actually
look at the source code.
And there you can actually
see all those responses.
So before in
Firebase Hosting, you
couldn't have these
dynamic type responses.
And this is a node
application through Express.
So here I'm actually
using fastbootMiddleware.
This is an Ember.js application.
I'm putting it on matching
star, and then I'm
exporting app as this.
And if I go to my
Firebase configuration,
I'm actually rewriting
the entire site
to go to that Cloud Function.
So star star goes to
that Cloud Function.
All right, back to the slides.
Well, before we had Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
Firebase developers, in order to
get any of this functionality,
would have had to spin
up their own servers.
That's a lot of cost.
You'd have to have DevOps.
You'd have to worry
about excess capacity.
And you'd have to worry about
how to connect to this API.
And you'd have to
respond with JSON.
You'd have to worry about
down network or slow network
connections, whereas
the Firebase SDKs take
care of all of this for you.
As a result, you would have
a lot, a lot of complexity.
Now, with Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
this is no longer the case.
You can actually spin
up a robust Node.js code
to listen to writes
on the database.
You can use the
Pub/Sub integration
to respond to any traditional
workers you might have.
And we have the
HTTPS, which take
in full Express applications.
And they can pull in any
of the powerful libraries
available to you on NPM.
So I hope I was
able to convince you
that with Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
you can do all of the things,
and you don't need a server.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]